من بين بنود المقترح الروسي لتركيا لوقف
عملياتها البريه المحتمله ضد المسلحين
لاكراد شمال شرقي سوريا بقاء قوات الاسايش
الكرديه في عين العرب كوباني ومنبج شمالي
سوريا بعد ادماجها في قوات النظام السوري
قوات الاسايش هي قوات الامن الداخلي في
المناطق الكرديه من شمال سوريا مصادر
تركيا اكدت الجزيره ان الوفد الروسي عرض
على تركيا ان تنسحب ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه المدعومه من الولايات المتحده
والتي تشكل وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
ابرز فصائلها ان تنسحب مع اسلحتها من عين
العرب وامن باشا ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه تبسط سيطرتها على مساحات
شاسعه من سوريا
تتجاوزوا
35,000 كلم مربع من مساحه سوريا البالغ
185,000 كلم مربع وتنتشر خاصه في الشمال
والشمال الشرقي ويبلغ عدد هذه القوات نحو
45 الف مقاتل على اقل تقدير اكثر من نصفهم
من العرب حسب بيان لوزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه لكن اللافته في المقترح الروسي
انه لم ياتي على ذكر تل رفعت واقتصر على
منبج وعين العرب كوباني رغم ان الاتراك
كانوا يريدون اخراج المسلحين الاكراد من
المدن الثلاثه مدينه تل رفعه تبعد 15 كيلو
مترا عن الحدود التركيه وتسيطر عليها وعلى
قرى قريبه منها وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
الوفد الروسي ابلغ الجانب التركي موافقه
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه على هذا المقترح
الشبيه باتفاق سوتشي التي لم يطبق شريطه
ضمان عدم حصول اجتياح تركي